anyone working at the SCP Foundation
will no doubt be familiar with scp-3008
also known as the infinite Ikea for
those of you that aren't it essentially
does what it says on the can or rather
it's assembled just like it is in the
flat pack Furniture instructions while
on the outside it appears to be an
average unassuming branch of the
affordable Swedish Furniture Outlet
inside is a different story crossing the
boundary of scp-3008's automatic doors
and venturing a little too deep into its
maze-like confines leads to an endless
Labyrinth of Cullens and hurdles a
dimensionally transcendental area that
defies our ordinary human understanding
of physical space lurking deep within
the aisles of the infinite Ikea rscp
3008-2s better known as the staff a race
of misshapen faceless humanoids with
long freakish arms that prey on anyone
that enters once Nightfall and yes there
are people inside
scp-3008 trapped Souls that have
wandered into the wrong Ikea only to end
up missing sometimes spending months or
even years inside if they ever get out
at all an alert was ringing filling the
air with loud blaring noise every member
of foundation Personnel stationed
outside the infinite Ikea was rushing
about guards standing at the ready the
storefront of scp-3008 had been silent
for quite a long while with nothing
reported going in or coming out but the
foundation knew far better than to
assume that scp-3008 didn't have
surprises in store for them pun fully
intended hey don't you dare click off we
know where you live in red right hand
are lining up the shot
anyway there appeared to be some kind of
commotion Beyond the Doors that quickly
slid open just in time for something to
be slung through the front entrance it
almost looked as if the Ikea itself had
spat something out like it was so toxic
it couldn't endure having to keep it
within its confines any longer
cautiously approaching with their
weapons raised the foundation's on-site
security team moved towards the
discarded mess to get a better look at
whatever it was it turned out to be a
person a man in around his late 50s
beaten within an inch of his life he was
wearing some kind of rudimentary circlet
or crown around his head seemingly
fashioned by hand out of stationery and
other materials scavenged from the paper
shop Department of the infinite Ikea
speaking of the man was wearing an Ikea
manager's uniform with a name tag pinned
to his chest that identified him as
Chris hanging from his neck was an Ikea
brand ended notepad with a message
sprawled on it but before you find out
what that message was we have another
important message for you one that
directly impacts you yes I'm talking
directly to you it comes from the
sponsor of today's video private
internet access we know you've heard a
lot of big claims from a lot of
different VPN providers but you
absolutely must hear why we've chosen
Pia as our personal VPN and why you
should do the same unlike the SCP
Foundation and some of those other VPN
Services out there Pia is the world's
most transparent VPN provider they never
record or store any user data at all
don't believe us their no log policy has
been proven multiple times in court and
was even verified by an independent
audit by Deloitte and they stay
transparent so that you don't have to
with Pia's VPN your IP address is hidden
and your connection is encrypted keeping
your Digital Life protected from the
prying eyes of network admins or even a
certain mobile task force unit and
they've just launched what is maybe
their coolest feature yet with servers
now in all 50 US states you can look
like you're surfing the web from exactly
where you want need to look like you're
checking out that SCP database entry
from Indiana they've got an IP address
for you there or maybe you're on the
west coast and want to catch the early
East Coast premiere of your favorite
show and avoid spoilers not a problem
with private internet access I could go
on and on about all the features I
regularly use but why not try it
yourself by going to
www.piavpn.com forward slash SCP and get
an 82 discount on private internet
access that's just two dollars eleven
cents a month plus get three extra
months completely for free not long
before Chris was found in his roughed up
State outside the only Ikea that goes on
forever he was working at a different
branch one that was much smaller on the
inside Chris was the manager of the
store and widely regarded by his
employees to be an awful person nobody
knew if he had always been that way or
if instilling him in a position of power
over other retail workers had somehow
caused him to develop a bit of a God
complex either way there was little he
ever did to invoke much camaraderie with
his colleagues whenever any of the
store's workers were on their breaks
which they usually had to remind Chris
were permitted by law and not optional
conversation often turned to their
Collective poor opinions of their
manager he'd been given the job out of
pretty blatant nepotism it was well
known how cozy Chris was with the
regional manager of all the Ikea stores
in the area on top of that Chris had a
pretty nasty habit of trying to force
his employees to stay behind after their
scheduled shifts had finished while also
refusing to pay them for overtime you
see it was his own mismanagement of the
work Rota that had left the store
understaffed at crucial moments of the
day the solution you would think should
be obvious hiring a few more new staff
to help with the workload and to start
their shifts at times when others were
about to clock out for the day ah but
new employees wouldn't work for free
their wages would come out of the
store's budget and why would Chris want
to take on new workers as the person in
charge of payroll he could help himself
to that money adding the wages of
prospective colleagues as a bonus on top
of his own unjustifiably exorbitant
salary perhaps the worst part about
having Chris as a manager was that he
seemed to get away with murder as long
as the store kept making a profit then
the management above him didn't care how
badly he treated his employees or
flouted the rules for his own game but
it was those same colleagues who had
suffered and been scorned by Chris's
Behavior who had finally had enough
retail work is hard having to deal with
rude and impolite customers on a
day-to-day basis working long hours of
uninteresting and repetitive labor all
for a paycheck that only just covered
rent like we said it is a hard line of
work and the people in it deserve the
utmost respect but you throw
megalomaniacal manager into the mix and
you've got a ticking time bomb on your
hands one that'll sooner or later
explode it was witnessing Chris
blatantly framing a younger member of
staff that finally triggered detonation
the kid had only been a student working
at Ikea all through his weekends to make
enough money to pay his bills Chris saw
this less experienced employee not as a
human being doing his best but a chance
to make a quick Buck by breaking the
rules the manager started stealing cash
from the register then blamed it on his
young staff member when the losses
started to show on the store's monthly
Financial reports seeing that for
themselves the other members of the
staff knew that it was the manager's
responsibility to empty the registers
regularly so they didn't have too much
cash in them in case of a robbery given
how much they all despise Chris it
didn't take much effort for the entire
Workforce to organize a walkout halfway
through the Working Day outraged Chris
had tried calling any colleagues that
were off shift barking at them to come
in and work on their days off all of
them said no the thing is when you work
in retail complaints to upper management
never seem to go anywhere like we said
if the store is making profit that's all
they care about but seeing such drastic
action from the staff of the store he
was supposed to be running the Ikea
higher-ups came down on Chris like a
hammer they instructed that he be sent
to another Ikea outlet for a whole
afternoon to receive some mandatory
interpersonal training little did anyone
realize that this was the last anyone
would ever see of him not that his old
staff was sad to hear that he had
disappeared arriving at what looked like
an ordinary Ikea Chris parked his car
outside the place seemed deserted no
customers filing in and out of the front
doors the only other vehicles in the
parking lot looking like they had just
been abandoned by their owners the
manager scoffed to himself these people
running this store we're going to teach
him how to do his job indignantly he
clipped his name tag on and stepped out
of his car marching across the asphalt
towards the entrance the automatic doors
gently slid open shutting smoothly
behind Chris as he stepped inside the
whole store was quiet barely a peep from
anywhere the high ceiling of the IKEA
store he so poorly managed carried a lot
of noise and made any sound Echo
throughout the building the squeaking of
shoes against the vinyl floors the
bustle of customers the electronic beep
of cash registers and the LOL dolled
music played over the intercom but there
was none of that here a deathly silence
filled the aisles of flat pack Furniture
display models of hemnises and tricials
standing as still and foreboding as
gravestones suddenly the sound of
movement reverberated from between one
row of aisles Chris began marching
towards its source expecting to find an
employee who would Point him in the
direction of the office where his
training was supposed to be conducted
sure enough within a few steps Chris
spotted a figure and a familiar bright
yellow t-shirt and blue pants the same
uniform his Ikea underlings wore at his
store excuse me he called as he Strode
towards the employee's shoes clomping
against the floor with every step you
need to tell me where your manager is
I'm from the store across town here for
some pointless training seminar Chris
hadn't waited until he was close enough
to engage in Pleasant conversation
instead making his demands as he
approached the figure in the Ikea
uniform however didn't turn to face him
hey I'm talking to you Chris shouted you
deaf or something there was a pause
telling Chris that what happened next
wasn't in response to what he said
although that didn't make it any less
frightening the figure who had been
hunched over near the floor suddenly
Drew itself up to its full height it
towered over Chris it must have measured
close to seven whole feet as it turned
the malignant manager saw its face or
that it didn't have one no eyes no mouth
nothing but a smooth surface without any
discernible features its arms were
elongated huge claw-like hands hanging
down to the creature's knees being a
coward Chris turned and ran immediately
confrontation was another area his
employees had noticed he was sorely
lacking in whenever faced with a rude
and cantankerous customer Chris would
never defend his colleagues or their
actions instead he would suck up and
brown nose two customers who were
clearly in the wrong essentially rolling
over the minute anyone raised their
voice so now confronted with a lumbering
faceless entity his self-preservation
instincts were kicked into overdrive had
he raced deeper into the store not
exactly in the best shape he slowed to a
halt wheezing as he tried to catch his
breath that was when looking around
Chris noticed just how long the aisles
seemed he was sure he would still be
able to see the front door from here yet
couldn't spot the entrance anywhere from
where he was currently standing panting
like a Thirsty Dog he looked over his
shoulder there was no sign of the staff
member he'd encountered little did Chris
know that it had lumbered off in the
opposite direction the second he had run
away from it hardly paying him any mind
at least while the lights were still on
unable to find the entrance or even a
fire door he couldn't escape through it
didn't take long for the lights inside
the infinite Ikea to dim marking the
start of the night cycle something about
it being darker made the sounds of
shuffling even more noticeable there
were more than one of those faceless
uniformed creatures trembling Chris
climbed inside a klepstad a wardrobe
with a sliding door barely able to sleep
with his knees tucked up under his chin
he spent the entire night inside the
cramped confined space every sound of
movement from outside brought with it
the mental image of one of the staffs
sliding open the outer door and reaching
down to grab him the whole Sleepless
while Chris couldn't help but think
about what he could have possibly done
to deserve this cruel fate the next
morning the lights came back on and
started to bleed through the seams of
the flat pack wardrobe waking Chris from
what little Restless sleep he had gotten
he paused unsure if he should venture
out in case he came across another one
of the staff suddenly he heard the sound
of voices muted and muffled by the door
of the klepstad the definitely real
human voices had it all been some
horrible nightmare had he fallen asleep
at work and been stuffed into a wardrobe
by his ungrateful employees oh now he
had them he would sue every last one of
them out of their jobs sliding the door
open and tumbling out of the clubstad
Chris found himself flying face down on
the store floor his legs too cramped to
move just as he tried to will them into
moving again a voice called out to him
hey mister it said you okay there a trio
of footsteps raced over to where he was
before he could get a good look at who
they belonged to hands were pulling
Chris up off the floor he looked at his
Rescuers bemused to see other people in
this endless void of affordable homeware
they were two men and a woman each in
disheveled clothing that looked like
they had been wearing the same thing for
years easy there fella one of the men
spoke names Buster which settlement you
from what do you mean by settlement
Chris asked confused looks like we got
another newbie the woman chuckled dryly
when'd you get here ah yesterday I think
the former manager answered time can be
a bit screwy in here the second man
chimed in I'm Nolan this here is Janine
you got a name uh Chris he nodded you
hungry Chris the three survivors LED
Chris through the winding expanse of the
Ikea without an end navigating The
Identical Isles with the expertise of
people that had been here long enough to
know their way around what felt like the
tiniest fraction of the time that he had
been lost the day before they brought
Chris to the food court it was bustling
with activity more so than the one at
his store with people patiently lining
up to take their fill of food from the
Ikea menu after joining the queue Buster
returned and handed Chris a plate of
Swedish meatballs with mashed potato
peas cream sauce and lingonberry Jam so
pleased to see food again Chris began to
gluttonously Devour the whole plate
while the others explained some of what
was going on here although he was barely
listening according to Janine who had
been there the longest the inside of
this Ikea was like an endless maze there
was no clear way out even when retracing
steps back the way one first entered
Nolan then weighed in and explained that
there were pockets of people who had
survived this long Inside scp-3008 by
forming their own little communities
thanks to the sheer amount of space
within the store these settlements were
almost the size of small townships built
using whatever Furniture appliances and
other materials the other survivors had
been able to scrounge up how come you
don't run out of food Chris interjected
it replenishes every day man Buster
replied gesturing to the food court
around them sure it's not ideal if you
aren't a huge fan of Ikea food but you
get used to it could be worse All Things
Considered then what the hell do you all
do for money the stubborn manager
demanded look around you Janine scoffed
we don't need it in here we're cut off
from the rest of the world stuff like
money hardly makes a difference can't
get us home or kept us Fed so what's the
point Chris side evidently frustrated at
the prospect of living inside in Ikea
yet not having the opportunity for
monetary gain so who's in charge he
asked who runs this place well no one
Nolan Shrugged settlements all work
together to help each other out if
needed but we don't have any singular
person running things hearing that out
loud caused a twisted idea to form in
Chris's balding head asking to be
escorted by Buster to the right aisle he
started Gathering up what he needed to
make a rudimentary Crown what's that for
Buster asked a little concerned about
what Chris was planning oh you wouldn't
understand he replied not looking up
from applying hot glue don't worry I'll
explain it in nice simple terms when I'm
ready that night despite being welcomed
into the Trio's town of lighting with
open arms Chris slipped back to the food
court while the other settlers were
sleeping carefully he avoided the
lurking staff and their drone calls of
the store is now closed please exit the
building reaching his destination the
malicious manager Lane wait for the next
morning Hiding Out Underneath the
counter where the food was served the
next morning the collected survivors of
the infinite Ikea were met with an
unfamiliar sight as they approached the
food court all the food food had gone it
had still replenished overnight like it
usually did but someone had gathered it
up before anyone had a chance to eat so
they topped the counter with a smug look
on his face Chris made a show of placing
his crown over his head morning everyone
he announced from today things are going
to be a little different around here but
I'm sure we'll be able to work together
like one big happy family holding the
gathered scp-3008 residents as his
literal captive audience all of them
hungry and irritable Chris outlined what
he had determined to be the best system
possible for how things should be run
inside the endless store I will keep all
the food secure and safe and we're gonna
start rationing it out he explained but
for a voice shot it from the crowd it
reappears every night anyway well here's
what we're gonna do if you just shut up
and let me finish Chris replied calmly
but with a condescending tone of
superiority according to Chris's grand
scheme every day each settlement would
be allocated what he deemed to be an
acceptable amount of ration food to feed
its population of survivors then he made
an offer to anyone who is willing to
help him if someone provided their
services and collecting the food each
morning and distributing the rationed
amount then Chris would allow them to
take an extra portion of rations just
for themselves you see now yes the crowd
oblivious to how many of them were
scowling at him anyone that wants to
help they get rewarded with a little bit
extra call it a bonus what if we don't
want to help you another onlooker called
well that's fine by me Chris sneered
back more for those who want it I think
what they mean is Janine shouted from
the group what if we don't want you to
implement this ridiculous system at all
what's to stop us from just taking the
food we need every morning like we did
before you showed up typical he tutted
how lazy you just want the privilege of
having more than you should work to earn
it and as for your silly little notion
of just taking I'm gonna be here every
morning I'll get to decide who eats and
who doesn't and how much they deserve
and if anyone wants to take make more
than they deserve without offering their
help in return then they'll get half of
the rations they would get and so will
their settlement so with those queries
out of the way allow me to introduce
myself as your new store manager when
they recovered Chris's body outside of
the entrance to scp-3008 the foundation
had no way of knowing exactly who had
beaten him up so badly the other
survivors inside the infinite Ikea might
have done it themselves while
overthrowing his short-lived stint as
manager or they might have decided not
to lower themselves to that level and
instead shunned him from entering their
settlements leaving him to fend for
himself with the staff around every
corner and their history of turning
aggressive towards humans come Nightfall
Chris's chances of survival were slim
the only real clue was the note that had
been found with him which read you can
have him back we don't want him now if
you aren't quite ready to check out of
the infinite Ikea then you should go and
check out life in the endless Ikea for
another tale of a trap soul in scp-3008
and then if you ever want suggestions on
what to do if you find yourself in the
same predicament then how to actually
beat scp-3008 the infinite Ikea is the
only Survival Guide You'll Ever Need